El pasado 1 de julio de 2017 se celebró el
150 cumpleaños de Canadá.
Os lo contamos en un pasado vídeo donde también
os mostramos las claves de porque Canadá
es uno de los países más admirados de todo
el mundo.
Sin embargo, aunque este país ha cumplido
150 años en plena forma, también se enfrenta
a problemas y amenazas sociales, políticas
y económicas que en algunos casos pueden
considerarse muy, como decirlo... bastante
serias.
Y es que, ya lo sabéis, nunca nada es completamente
de color de rosas.
Pues bien, si en el anterior vídeo, cuyo
enlace por cierto, os dejo al final de este
y también en la descripción, nos centramos
en las luces, en este vamos a acercarnos a
las principales sombras y amenazas que se
ciernen sobre Canadá.
Y la primera de ellas, tiene mucho que ver
precisamente con este 150 aniversario.
UN CUMPLEAÑOS UN TANTO… ¿ARTIFICIAL?
No todos los canadiense, ni muchos menos,
han celebrado este 150 cumpleaños.
Podemos encontrar diferentes razones pero
para explicarlas lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es ver qué se ha celebrado exactamente
con este aniversario.
Así que, echemos la vista atrás en el tiempo,
vayamos hasta 1867.
El 1 de julio de ese año, cuando, como todos
sabéis, este territorio formaba parte del
imperio británico, se firmó la primera Acta
Británica para Norte América.
(La “British North Ameria Act de 1867 fue
una ley que unió a las entonces tres provincias
coloniales de Nueva Brunswick, Nueva Escocia
y Canadá - que ese mismo día, por cierto,
se dividió en Ontario y Quebec - en la Confederación
de Canadá).
Pues bien, sobre estas cuatro provincias,
que mantuvieron bastante autonomía, se colocó
un gobierno federal que… las diese cierta
cohesión.
Por supuesto, sobre este gobierno federal
continuaba estando las autoridades británicas.
(De hecho, Canadá sigue siendo a día de
hoy una monarquía y la reina de Inglaterra,
Isabel II sigue ocupando la jefatura del estado.
Es más, aunque parezca sorprendente y de
facto la autonomía fuese total, Canadá no
alcanzó la plena independencia del Reino
Unido hasta prácticamente antes de ayer,
hasta 1982).
Sí, tal como lo escucháis, hasta 1982, cualquier
modificación constitucional requería formalmente
el visto bueno de las autoridades británicas.
El caso, como veis, es que la ley de 1867
no dio lugar a un país completamente independiente.
Y si encima tenemos en cuenta que todo el proceso
fue llevado a cabo por la minoría que formaba
la élite blanca podemos comprender porque
muchos colectivos no están precisamente por
entusiasmados con este aniversario.
Y sobre todos ellos, el más importante es
el de los pueblos precoloniales… porque
amigos, Canadá no era una tierra vacía...
LAS PRIMERAS NACIONES, LOS INUITS Y LOS MÉTIS
Cerca de millón y medio de canadienses no
tuvieron nada que celebrar el pasado 1 de julio.
Hablamos de las personas que pertenencen a
los pueblos indígenas.
(“Este aniversario es una celebración de
los peores 150 años de vida de los pueblos
indígenas".
Pero no penseis que se trata de un problema
histórico, para nada.
El reconocimiento y la integración de estos
pueblos aún siguen siendo un problema nacional.
De hecho, el gobierno de Justin Trudeau lo
considera como una prioridad, fijaos lo claro
que fue el propio Primer Ministro el pasado
21 de junio de 2017, el día nacional de los aborígenes.
("Ninguna relación es más importante para
nuestro gobierno y para Canadá que la de
los pueblos indígenas")
Pero… claro, puede que os estéis preguntando
¿quiénes son estos grupos?
y ¿Qué problemas han sufrido?
(Pues bien, según la propia Constitución
de Canadá hablamos de tres grandes grupos:
las Primeras Naciones, que comprenden más
de 600 comunidades indias; los inuits que
como todos sabemos eran y son los pobladores
del ártico; y los Métis, resultado de la
mezcla de aborígenes y colonos).
Y es que, amigos, Canadá cuando llegaron
los colonos europeos no era una tierra vacía.
Se estima que por aquel vivián unas 500.000
personas pertenecientes a estos pueblos indígenas
que firmaron acuerdos con las autoridades
francesas y británicas.
De hecho, participaron en batallas que protegieron
la independencia de Canadá.
("Canadá sería estadounidense hoy si no
fuera por los aliados indios que lucharon
por la Corona".
Sí, los Estados Unidos trataron de invadir
Canadá en alguna que otra ocasión...
(Pues bien, el caso es que a pesar de ser
pobladores de estos territorios antes de la
llegada de los colonos, y de contribuir a
la independencia de este territorio, los indígenas
sufrieron una auténtica persecución cultural).
Así es, fruto de esa obsesión que algunos
tienen por crear identidades homogéneas y
nacionales por encima de todo, en Canadá
se desató toda una persecución contra el indio.
Durante años, los pueblos indígenas sufrieron
la ocupación de sus territorios y se les
concentró en reservas que en muchos casos
no reunían las mínimas condiciones para
garantizar su supervivencia.
Asimismo tanto sus lenguas como sus ritos
religiosos y culturales fueron perseguidos
y en muchos casos prohibidos.
Esta obsesión por la ingeniería social llegó
hasta tal punto que las autoridades pusieron
en marcha un sistema de residencias e internados
para niños de estas familias indígenas.
(El gobierno le quitaba los niños a las familias
y los internaba en estos lugares para que
recibiesen una educación estrictamente “occidental”
y perdieran cualquier rasgo de su cultura).
Decenas de miles de niños pasaron por estos
lugares.
Y ojo, porque estos colegios estuvieron funcionando
hasta los 70 y las consecuencias, claro, llegan
hasta hoy:
tasas de pobreza muy por encima de la media,
familias rotas, depresiones, alcoholismo y
tasas de suicidios también anormalmente altas.
Estas son, amigos, las consecuencias de la
ingeniería social.
Junto a ello, el racismo y la exclusión fueron
habituales y aún hoy existen muchos casos
criminales por resolver, algunos cometidos
hace no tanto tiempo.
(En 2008, el entonces primer ministro, Stephen
Harper, pidió perdón a estos pueblos por
los atropellos cometidos y se estableció
la Comisión de la Verdad y la Reconciliación.
También han pagado cientos de millones en
indemnizaciones a la comunidad, pero eso por
si mismo nunca arregla los problemas).
El caso es que hoy este nuevo Canadá
aun busca la mejor manera de pasar página.
Y de este conflicto social y político, pasemos
a uno de mucha mayor actualidad: Estados Unidos
y Donald Trump.
LA AMENAZA DE RUPTURA
Canadá, amigos, es un país muy dependiente de su
relación con los Estados Unidos,
tanto que casi podríamos decir que los canadienses no podrían vivir sin sus vecinos los yanquis.
Fijaos, casi el 70% de todo el comercio canadiense
tiene como destino su vecino del sur.
No solo eso, el sector industrial de Canadá
también está
tremendamente interconectado con el de Estados Unidos.
Vamos, que la relación es muy especial.
Todo esto es algo que Justin Trudeau ha tenido
siempre bastante claro.
Lo dijo en campaña y nada más llegar al
poder concentró buena parte de la agenda
internacional en mejorar aún más las relaciones
con Estados Unidos.
Y la verdad, el tándem que formó con Obama
fue casi de película.
Pero... en esas llegó al poder Donald Trump con toda
su retórica proteccionista
¿Y que hizo el gobierno canadiense?
Pues montar una especie de “sala de guerra”,
de oficina dedicada a seguir todos los pasos
de la nueva administración de Washington.
Al principio la estrategia de Trudeau hacia
Trump y su entorno fue la seducción,y todo
sea dicho parece que la cosa funcionó.
El Primer Ministro canadiense incluso logró
trazar amistad con Ivanka Trump, la propia
hija del nuevo inquilino de la Casa Blanca.
“Ivanka Trump se va al teatro con Justin
Trudeau”.
Lo que ya os podéis imaginar, dio rienda
suelta a todo tipo de especulaciones.
El caso es que hubo química y ambos lideraron
un panel sobre mujeres y negocios del que
se hizo eco el propio Donald Trump en el mismísimo
discurso ante el congreso.
“Con la ayuda del primer ministro Justin
Trudeau hemos formado un Comité con nuestro
vecinos en Canadá para asegurarnos de ayudar
a las mujeres emprendedoras a tener acceso
a redes, mercados y al capital necesario para
iniciar sus negocios y alcanzar sus sueños
financieros”
Vamos, que todo parecía ir viento en popa…
pero esperad un momento porque de repente
un buen día Trump se lanzó al cuello canadiense
y les acusó de competencia desleal, algo
que como todos sabéis también hizo con México.
Ante el peligro que supondría para Canadá
una restricción en las relaciones comerciales
entre ambos países, el gobierno de Ottawa
no se amilanó y lanzó la que ha sido bautizada
como “Estrategia Donut” que consiste en
influir sobre todos los órganos de Washington
alrededor de la Casa Blanca, que se situaría
en, claro, en el agujero del donut.
Congresistas, Senadores, Gobernadores....
los funcionarios y políticos canadienses
han comenzado una auténtica gira por los
Estados Unidos.
(De momento parece estar funcionando y el
apoyo en Washington hacia Canadá parece crecido.
Pero solo el tiempo nos dirá cómo termina
la renegociación del NAFTA, que fijará los
nuevos términos en las relaciones comerciales
entre ambos países).
Ahora la pregunta es ¿Conseguirán su objetivo?
Pues bien, la siguiente etapa que nos espera
es una potencial crisis que según muchos
expertos puede amenazar la prosperidad canadiense.
LA BURBUJA INMOBILIARIA
En la última década los precios de las casas
en Canadá se han disparado un 76%, al tiempo
que los préstamos bancarios se han disparado.
Hoy la deuda de las familias canadienses se
encuentra entre las más altas del mundo.
Fijaos en este gráfico para ver que ha pasado con los precios de las casas.
Y la deuda de las familias:
Y ya podéis imaginar que esto es algo que
ha disparado todas las alarmas por el riesgo
que algunos perciben de que Canadá pudiera
enfrentarse a la explosión de una burbuja
inmobiliaria y sus consecuencias sobre la
economía y las finanzas.
(Al fin y al cabo casi el 7% de los empleos
en este país están en la construcción,
y gracias a este boom hipotecario 3 bancos
canadienses se han situado entre los 20 más
grandes del mundo).
De hecho, amigos, el valor de mercado, el
Royal Bank of Canadá es más grande que cualquier
banco de la zona euro.
¿Estaremoos ante una burbuja condena a explotar?
Desde luego esta es una de las prioridades
hoy del gobierno: impulsar otros sectores,
tratar de enfriar el sector inmobiliario y
mantener en la medida de lo posible una demanda
que estabilice este mercado.
Tal vez la intención de incrementar en un
50% la llegada de inmigrantes cada año tenga
mucho que ver en esto.
Más inmigrantes suponen más demanda de vivienda.
De todas formas, ojo, otros expertos recuerdan
que los bancos canadienses no estuvieron afectados
por la crisis financiera de 2008 y que son
más robustos que otros bancos internacionales...
al tiempo que la economía en Canadá marcha
bien y que de hecho está cojiendo fuerza
tras un par de años…. regulares.
En fin, el tiempo dirá, pero desde luego
este es un riesgo que tiene al gobierno muy
pendiente.
Y de la economía, pasamos a los servicios
públicos.
LAS LISTAS DE ESPERA
En Canadá la sanidad es un servicio público
gestionado y financiado por el gobierno…
con los impuestos de los contribuyentes claro.
De hecho, es considerado uno de los mejores
del mundo, sin embargo tiene algunos problemas
que empiezan a ser “pesados”
El más importante es el de las listas de
espera.
Según estudios del instituto Fraser ver a
un especialista implica una espera media de
18 semanas ¡más de 4 meses!
Un tiempo que se ha duplicado en los últimos
25 años y que no parece que tenga fácil
solución teniendo en cuenta el envejecimiento
demográfico y el incremento de la esperanza
de vida.
(Todo esto ha provocado que cada año decenas
de miles de canadienses se desplacen a Estados
Unidos para recibir atención médica y que
incluso se haya hecho relativamente popular
contratar seguros médicos en el país vecino).
En fin, estos son los principales retos y
amenazas a los que se enfrenta el gobierno
de Justin Trudeau.
Cómo os decía en el vídeo anterior sobre
los 150 años de Canadá, no todo es de color
de rosas.
Eso sí, el resultado final del cóctel canadiense
parece bastante bueno.
En fin, turno para ti.
¿Te gustaria vivir y trabajar una temporada
en Canadá?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y suscribete al canal.
Y Si quieres conocer el mejor lado de Canadá
no te pierdas este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.